[Music]
you've known about this since november
we'd like you to do the right thing and
do your job
can you please just do your job we all
pay you to do your job this is not
political this is no it's not political
it's unprofessional no it's not you
don't like it you don't like the truth
a contentious day as the fallout
continues over the death of college
student nathan valencia at a fraternity
event good afternoon thanks for joining
us at four i'm kirsten joyce and i'm
christian casa there's some fighting
going on outside the ring as the nevada
state athletic commission addresses the
deadly fraternity boxing match the
chairman lambasting metro police for
failing to investigate the tragedy
further the 8 news now i-team first shed
light on the unregulated fight vanessa
murphy is here with the latest on what
unfolded today vanessa some tense
moments at this meeting to say the least
the chairman slamming metro police and
sheriff joe lombardo and ripping into an
assistant district attorney saying they
all dropped the ball in handling this
tragic case
you guys have
already doubled down you're going to
triple down today
or you're going to come to grips with
the situation sir i'd like to explain no
no i'm going to ask you i'm asking you a
question my opinion my question
undo an answer
i'll do an answer are you going to
triple down today are you going to come
in and do the right thing
i'm asking you to answer binary
questions either yes or no
you represent metro nevada state
athletic commission chairman stephen
klubeck addressing metro deputy chief
james la rochelle this is after the
nevada attorney general's office
released this
158-page investigative report into this
fraternity boxing match in november
20-year old nathan valencia collapsed
after his fight and died four days later
a key finding by investigators metro
police failed to investigate whether
foul play was involved at the
unregulated event they all fall into the
state umbrella where metro does not
deputy chief la rochelle telling the
commission metro police did review the
case along with the clark county
district attorney's office chairman
klubeck also ripping into assistant d.a
christopher lawley i received a copy of
the report this morning
and i am not in any position whatsoever
to comment on the report so how could
you come to a meeting
when you got a certified letter
from this commission
putting you on notice
that you were being talked about you're
not prepared i didn't
know you just said you're not prepared
you said you didn't read anything and
you're not prepared
i didn't receive a copy of the report
that means you're not prepared
chairman klubeck later apologized to the
assistant d.a so what happens now there
may be a meeting with metro police the
district attorney's office and the
commission to take another look at that
deadly fraternity boxing match we first
obtained the investigative report
yesterday you can find much more
information at eight newsnow dot com and
coming up at six we'll have much more on
what unfolded today